dépenser un sou tien quelques mots sur
un cahier tout au long de la journée les
habitants de vélizy se sont succédé
devant la mairie pour faire part de
leurs condoléances
la famille française de nora quoirin est
originaire de ce village son grand père
en est maire tous ici se sentent touchés
par le drame
c'est normal tant d'erreurs ça nous a
fait quelque chose on l'a suivi à la
télévision la bomba on voit le maire
mais on ne dit rien par par sp ça
m'émeut quoi ça m'émeut de de voir qu'on
peut s'en prendre à une petite fille
enfin une adolescente on veut dire
vulnérables cesser ces affreuses qui ce
qui leur arrive
comment expliquer ça l'annnonce de
l'identification du corps de la jeune
fille hier a été un choc n'aura 15 ans
était attendu ce week end en vacances
chez ses grands-parents à son retour de
malaisie pour son grand père sa
disparition restent un mystère
maintenant il faut faire son deuil le
deuil nécessite des réponses aux
questions qui se sont posées pourquoi et
du comment
c'est cela qu'il faut maintenant
travailler et on compte bien sûr les
institutions pour qu'on trouve sa
réponse en malaisie l'autopsié du corps
a eu lieu ce mercredi les résultats
pourraient apporter deux premiers
éléments sur les circonstances du décès
de nora karl enquête se poursuit sur
place après les recherches qui ont
mobilisé des centaines de personnes les
proches de la jeune fille ne croit pas à
une fugue et le parquet de paris a
ouvert une enquête pour enlèvement et
séquestration
un long parcours judiciaire attend
encore la famille de cagnottes ont été
ouvertes sur internet pour les assister
dans cette procédure à l'autre bout du
monde